Nicolas Sarkozy il y a 10 ans qui
fustigé et qui se moquaient des
écologistes et maintenant qui se
présente comme le premier écologiste il
faut qu'il récupère la récupération
c'est de la prise de conscience quand il
a été élu il savait très bien les
problèmes climatiques et tout ça c'est
pas possible nous on le sait on appelle
j'ai pas fait d'études
je fais du rap moi je suis au courant
alors que le chien rebond soit vous êtes
ici pour un nouvel album intitulé crise
de conscience
alors il y a quatre ans ils viennent
annoncé que dernier round était votre
dernier round qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
alors ça avait été annoncé parce que
j'avais donc un label à l'époque qui
fait qu'à ce moment là j'ai préféré
mettre ma carrière de côté en croyance
sincèrement que c'était la fin pour moi
mais en 2006 j'ai dû vendre le label
soit parce qu'on faisait des mauvaises
soit parce que le téléchargement a
beaucoup âgé sur la musique et donc
comme je me suis rendu compte que je
savais pas faire grand chose d'autre
vous étiez chez vous il y a des potes
qui passaient pour vous faire écouter
des textes pour écouter des instruits
tout ça puis voilà vous ai dit je peux
pas rester là à faire le café
retourner au truc alors il faut dire
aussi qu'il y avait une reformation de
NTM pour une tournée à guichet fermée et
ça vous a aussi donné envie de de faire
un album c'est vrai que le fait aussi de
de voir l'enthousiasme qui a eu autour
de l'ETM ça ça m'a donné que que bien
sûr pour continuer alors pendant la
tournée que vous avez fait avec Joey
Starr donc il a été incarcéré pour pour
violence
un jour il est descendu à 5h du matin
j'ai cherché des clopes en tong et en
jogging il y a des mecs qui sont foutus
de sa gueule il allait chercher un
hachoir
c'est tout Joey
quand même ouais
c'est pas bien grave en même temps bah
tant qu'on s'en sert pas pour taper sur
les gens ça va être juste pour
impressionner comme ça
c'est vrai que son singe est venu le
voir en cage pour se moquer de lui
alors voilà donc tout ça vous est obligé
à faire des concerts en solo
gratuitement pour payer les pénalités
d'annulation
vous savez beaucoup de choses alors
c'est dommage parce que votre
réconciliation avec Joey avait été un
événement c'est qui qui avait fait le
premier pas à votre banquier
non notre manager à votre manette un peu
pareil
alors voilà alors Joey quand même
présent sur l'album prise de conscience
dans le single que tout le monde écoute
en ce moment qui s'appelle je reviens
c'est marrant parce que pendant le clip
vous voyez cool il faisait ça comme ça
et vous non
alors chez lui c'est un réflexe de
Pavlov voilà comme ça vous non plus
mais comment vous les faire élire dans
le 9 3 ou dans le 9-2 ou dans le 9 5 si
vous avez pas faire ça
j'ai un fils qui essaie déjà ça va
alors pourquoi vous étiez engueulé il y
a 10 ans il avait il avait rencontré
yokono ou quoi non bon ça faisait déjà
enfin ça faisait 10 ans qu'on faisait de
la musique ensemble mais ça faisait déjà
20 ans qu'on se connaît c'est et puis et
puis on commençait à avoir des vues un
peu différentes et sur la musique et
puis aussi sur la vie quoi on était de
plus en plus éloignés chacun va un peu
son cercle et
puis trop là il va très bien il va très
bien il y a même pris 10 kg
non plus mais je vous dirai l'enfant
tout le monde m'a dit qu'il est mordu en
rottweiler c'est pas vrai c'est faux
c'est l'école
[Musique]
on passe maintenant au commentaire de
l'actualité de la semaine avec l'édito
de Blacko hein et c'est Thomas Legrand
l'éditorialiste de France Inter que nous
retrouverons après le magnéto sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
tous les chefs d'État de la planète se
réunissent à Copenhague pour sauver le
monde et pour bien montrer que notre
avenir est en jeu on a mis des enfants
partout des chorales d'enfants des
affiches avec des visages d'enfants des
dessins d'enfants des œuvres d'art à
base d'enfants qui se noie et cerise sur
le gâteau un joli petit film d'ouverture
pour bien [ __ ] la trouille aux enfants
bah ouais pour expliquer le danger aux
enfants pas la peine de leur expliquer
avec des mots compliqués il suffit de
leur [ __ ] la trouille
alors ma petite tu as bien compris oui
papa mais à la télé ils disent qu'un
enfant meurt de faim toutes les six
secondes pourquoi on organise pas un
sommet contre la faim même à petite
chérie on a déjà organisé un sommet sur
la fin dans le monde c'était en novembre
à Rome sauf que personne n'en a parlé
car aucun membre du G8 avait fait le
déplacement c'est à dire qu'il n'avait
pas trop envie de verser les 44
milliards prévus pour aider les enfants
qui meurent de faim mais dis-moi papa
pourquoi on n'empêche pas les enfants de
mourir de faim ben enfin chéri la
surpopulation c'est très mauvais pour la
planète allez fais comme Papa ferme les
yeux n'y penses plus gros bisous
[Musique]
voilà c'était les vidéos de Blacko mise
en images de Julien grappe Thomas le
grand bonsoir donc Thomas Legrand tous
les matins à 7h46 sur France Inter les
plus écouté on est très heureux de vous
avoir avec nous ce soir vous êtes un
homme de radio vous avez pourtant un
physique tout à fait acceptable
alors la France est qualifiée pour
Copenhague
c'est déjà pas mal
alors
l'objectif à Copenhague c'est de se
mettre d'accord pour savoir si on va
crever en 2020 en 2030 ou en 2050 voilà
c'est quand même vous avez pas l'air
persuadé de ce que je dis vous non je
suis optimiste de nature
il faut éviter donc que la température
monte de 2 degrés et pour ça il faut
qu'on réduise nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de 40% d'ici 10 ans vous
voyez bien que c'est mort
mais j'aurais dû de 12 à 16% l'espace de
quelques années je vois pas pourquoi on
n'arrivait pas
à s'y mettre contrairement à ce que tout
le monde disait ce que tout le monde
pensait s'y mettre c'est eux qui nous
demandent de consommer moins parce que
eux c'est vrai que même s'ils ont une
croissance exponentielle il consomme
encore beaucoup moins que que nous en
tout cas que les États-Unis 3 ou 4 fois
moins par chinois électrique qui sont
dans la voiture électrique
de plus en plus moderne beaucoup plus
moderne que les nôtres et moins
polluantes que les nôtres nucléaire mais
c'est vrai que sur l'électricité ils
sont ils sont bien en avance sur les
nouveaux véhicules
un accord pas très contraignant
finalement
contraignant et puis il faut surtout la
façon de le contrer et il faut le
contrôler et surtout parce que c'est
pour ça il faut placer des satellites
pour vérifier que les États tiennent
bien leurs engagements mais nous on a
été à Hanoï avec le Premier ministre au
Vietnam le Vietnam il y a un cinquième
du Vietnam qui sous l'eau dans 15 ans si
on fait rien donc il y a des populations
qui sont très très mobilisées moi je
suis optimiste je crois pas qu'il
sortira des choses très concrètes de
Copenhague mais c'est un pas en avant on
voit d'ailleurs que les pays donne
dégage leur bonne volonté la position de
l'Amérique par exemple s'est transformée
depuis Kyoto prochain les gens c'est
Mexico je crois dans un an je pense
qu'on peut espérer que le Mexico il
sentira quelque chose Mexico c'est le
meilleur idée pour faire un sommet sur
l'écologie parce que moi là-bas il fait
chaud il y a de la pollution et des gaz
d'échappement alors que Copenhague il
fait froid c'est une très mauvaise idée
entre la position du conseiller pour la
science de George Bush il y a deux ans
et conseillé pour la science d'Obama qui
n'oubliez pas ça Nicolas Sarkozy a
disons qu'il fustigé et qui se moquaient
des écologistes maintenant qui se
présente comme le premier écologiste et
il a raison il faut qu'il récupère la
récupération c'est de la prise de
conscience quand il a été élu il savait
très bien les problèmes climatiques et
tout ça c'est
pas possible nous on le sait on appelle
j'ai pas fait d'études
je fais du rap moi je suis au courant
[Musique]
c'est comme c'est comme de s'étonner des
traders et tout ça de lui alors que bon
Sarkozy ici quand même à fond si c'était
pas aussi clair quand il a vu que les
écologistes et que Hulot pourrait faire
15% s'il tient qu'est-ce qui se passe et
là maintenant
il faut pas rire quand on parle de prise
de conscience c'est pas inutile une
prise de conscience mais les choses vont
lentement c'est 2050 c'est 2100 euh 2050
mon pauvre Philippe
en 2050
tu continueras à faire des émissions à
Canal+ de l'époque
la durée du chef mais est-ce qu'il y a
pas plus important je sais pas moi l'eau
la fin enfin c'est quand même des
problèmes c'est complètement lié et la
fin aussi pourquoi les chefs d'État ils
vont pas quand il y a un sommet sur
l'eau ou sur la fin ils vont tous à
Copenhague on peut peut-être on fait le
procès des politiques là on peut aussi
faire de temps en temps le procès des
opinions est-ce que les gens sont les
gens sont prêts à faire les sacrifices
nécessaires n'arrête pas de juger les
politiques je voudrais que
c'est une mesure absolument
indispensable l'écologie mais surtout
pas de taxe carbone et les gens n'en
veulent pas c'est ce qu'ils font les
gens ils laissent pas couler l'eau quand
il se lave les dents il pisse sous la
douche façon
et la position de Claude Alex vous en
pensez quoi il est tout seul à penser ce
qu'il pense et aussi il était tout seul
il est top cédé par Galilée seul contre
tous ça met le doute dans les dans
l'esprit des gens et finalement je me
demande si la majorité de l'opinion
n'est pas plutôt du côté de Claude Alex
parce que c'est quand même plus
confortable du côté de kodale
qui se réunissent en un même lieu et du
de toute la planète et qui décide qu'il
y a un consensus scientifique
qui était tout seul contre des religieux
pas pareil bien on continue notre
commentaire d'activité de la semaine
avec l'édito de Blacko 2
[Musique]
voilà quand plein débats sur l'identité
nationale on parle de supprimer les
cours d'histoire en terminale
scientifique mais bon sang la lettre de
Guy Moquet c'était juste un plan de com
tout ce qu'on apprend pendant les cours
d'histoire la résistance la
collaboration les camps d'extermination
c'est pas si important de l'apprendre
mais enfin comment voulez-vous préparer
l'avenir sans prendre conscience du
passé si on veut vraiment savoir ce que
c'est que la France c'est pas en faisant
un sondage sur Internet qu'on va le
savoir mieux vaut se tourner vers les
grands hommes qui ont fait l'histoire de
notre pays je vous ai toujours dit la
vérité ah non moi je voyais encore plus
grand
alors mon général c'est quoi votre idée
de la France je me fais un effet de la
France une certaine idée soyez plus
précis je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens
oui elle est quelque chose et de quoi de
très grand de très particulier mais
c'est un peu vague la France est une
chose oui alors à mes yeux oui
très considérable très valable voilà
mais boire et elle doit avoir un rôle à
elle mais quel rôle il faut que la
France joue son rôle c'était quoi comme
rôle il faut qu'elle soit à la France il
faut que la France soit la France ah bah
bravo la définition comme quoi la France
c'est pas forcément ceux qui l'aiment le
plus qui en parle le mieux enfin si
c'est ça les grandes leçons du passé
c'est peut-être pas une si mauvaise idée
de supprimer l'histoire en terminale S
bravo
bravo Blacko bravo Julien
moi je trouve que c'est vachement bien
qu'on se moque de De Gaulle parce que
maintenant tout le monde nous parle de
Gaulle toute la journée la gauche la
droite le sang du monde est pour de
Gaulle et là on voit bien que bon voilà
à quoi c'était pas non plus toujours
très bien ce qu'il disait de Gaulle du
jazz
à chaque fois il disait des choses comme
ça la France et la France la République
c'est la République
donc en plein débat sur l'identité
nationale on parle de supprimer
l'histoire en terminale S
l'histoire-géo sera remplacée par des
cours de télémarketing pour préparer les
lycéens alors vie professionnelle
n'importe quoi on fait une réforme du
lycée et réorganise les enseignements on
augmente le temps d'histoire en première
et on fait passer le bac d'histoire en
première comme on fait passer le bac de
français en première pour les
scientifiques et les scientifiques qui
veulent en terminale continuer une
histoire ils peuvent même la prendre en
option donc c'est c'est franchement une
mauvaise querelle on peut regretter
quand terminal les scientifiques ne
fassent plus d'histoires en France ils
ont envie d'en faire aujourd'hui ils ont
deux heures et demie en première ils en
auront quatre mais c'est pas la même
chose c'est-à-dire que pendant un an il
faut plus d'histoire
comme une agence
on fait une réforme du lycée il y a des
filières qui sont un peu spécialisés
soit on dit tout le monde apprend la
même chose c'est une autre option
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des jeunes Valérie
qui croient que la guerre d'Indochine
c'est la dispute entre les frères Sirkis
[Applaudissements]
si cette polémique prend cette ampleur
c'est parce que il y a ce débat à la con
sur l'identité nationale qui teinte
cette petite polémique et qu'il a gonfle
comme une baudruche et c'est ça qui
pollue qui pollue même jusqu'à la
réforme des lycées qui est pas si mal de
toute façon qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
depuis 45 à part les Beatles
on va parler maintenant de l'identité
nationale qui est toujours abordée sous
l'angle de la religion de l'immigration
en ce moment
il faut mais là il faut un débat il faut
un débat sur l'identité nationale c'est
des gens qui balancent sur les Arabes
alors moi je vais vous dire si si vous
le savez bien si alors je vais vous dire
une seconde tomate national non c'est
quoi c'est la solidarité la sécurité la
retraite c'est les études gratuites
c'est l'hôpital pour tout le monde c'est
la justice c'est les services publics
c'est 5 semaines de vacances qu'on
trouve ça bien ou pas c'est la culture
c'est la liberté d'expression c'est ça
l'identité nationale quand on regarde
les résultats du boulot de Besson c'est
des gens qui se réunissent dans des
mairies pour balancer sur les Arabes
dans la liste que tu viens de faire tu
as tu as oublié un élément auquel il ne
faut évidemment pas réduire l'identité
nationale mais dont il faut tenir compte
dans la liste des éléments qui
constituent l'identité nationale c'est
l'immigration c'est évident les apports
positifs de l'immigration y contribue à
constituer et pourquoi parce que le
débat sur l'identité nationale
en permanence des populations nouvelles
qui arrivent je peux les intégrer il
faut savoir autour de quelle valeur on
les intègre qu'est-ce qu'on leur propose
qu'est-ce qu'on leur dit c'est quoi la
France c'est quoi la France qu'on va
rejoindre et qu'est-ce qu'on leur et
qu'est-ce qu'on leur propose qu'est-ce
qu'on leur demande aussi parce que il y
a des gestes à faire mais il y aura même
pas de réponse à la finale on va faire
un débat où il y aura rien qui n'a rien
à s'en sortir il y a rien qui va sortir
rien
vont se lâcher contre les musulmans
voilà ce qui se passe depuis le début de
ce débat le président de la République
s'exprime pour la première fois dans le
monde et il le fait à l'occasion du
débat sur les minarets et commence par
par cette en plus parlé des minarets
pour parler de l'identité nationale
c'est pas c'est pas complètement dévoyé
mais le papier sur le lit attentivement
sur les devoirs et sur les droits je
trouve qu'il a tout à fait raison
exactement
qu'est-ce que tu crois et après
qu'est-ce que c'est la politique
Front national en même temps les
Français sont très mal à l'aise il faut
bien le dire la majorité des Français
sont mal à l'aise avec le problème du
l'immigration il faut que le moins que
il faut que moi il faut que cette mais
non
mais la preuve la preuve attends la
preuve c'est que les actions du Front
national sont actuellement en train de
remonter ça prouve qu'il y a un malaise
il y a un dit il y a non dit inconscient
inconscient il y a une frustration il y
a un problème il faudrait que une fois
pour toute ce problème là les données de
ce problème là soit posé sur la table
alors c'est peut-être idiot de le faire
à la veille d'une campagne électorale je
suis d'accord mais c'est pas mauvais que
ces choses là soient dites et qu'on
défoule enfin ce qu'on a sur le cœur
mais incroyable président doit défouler
ce qu'on a sur le cœur alors
de l'identité
il est là pour la cohérence des Français
tout ramène toujours à débat sur Sarkozy
on en a marre
on a parlé de toi
qui mélange tout donc c'est normal
est-ce qu'il y a un en France un
problème de comportement de mentalité ou
non provoqué par l'immigrations
et de la diversité tous les sondages le
montrent et il vient nous nous proposer
un débat comme ça pour tout raviver vous
parlez du refoulé mais là on est dans le
défouloir et je suis là je suis pas sûr
alors maintenant le mot de la fin moi je
crois pas que les gens spécialement
contre Sarkozy c'est contre le sujet qui
est élevé qu'on trouve assez stupide moi
je vois pas comment on peut définir
l'identité française et tous aller dans
un espèce de tous le même sens on
devrait tous se penser pareil avec des
valeurs pareil les valeurs c'est la
République et c'est la loi que nous
impose la République et c'est ça qu'on
de suivre exactement à ce moment là on
est français après on peut penser
différemment voilà
c'est donner une définition de
ités
national c'est compliqué
[Applaudissements]
nationale c'est s'engueuler toute la
journée surtout et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu